bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pendant la suspension
des travaux du Sénat je vous propose de
voir ou de revoir les temps fort de la
dernière session parlementaire et place
ce matin aux travaux de la commission
des finances sur l'évasion et la
frautete fiscale dans le siillage des
révélations des Panama papers la
commission des finances a effectué au
printemps et allaité des auditions sur
ces thèmes elle a concentré une partie
de ses efforts sur les banques et elle a
AINS vu s'exprimer la Société Générale
le 11 mai banque mise en cause dans le
scandale panaméen mais ce n'était pas la
première fois que Frédéric oua le
directeur de la Société Générale
s'exprimait devant les sénateurs en
avril 2012 devant la commission
d'enquête sur le rôle des banques dans
l'évasion fiscale des capitaux il avait
affirmé sous sererement que la banque
avait fermé ses implantations au Panama
le sénateur ERC booker rapporteur de
cette commission d'enquête avait estimé
au vu des révélations des Panama papers
que de telles déclarations pouvaient
donner lieu à des poursuites pour faux
témoignage mais depuis le bureau du
Sénat n'a pas donné suite mais c'est
donc dans ce climat tendu que s'est
déroulé cette audition tout de suite
donc retour à l'audition de Frédéric
oudea j'ai demandé à Frédéric oudea qui
dirige une banque systémique qui a été
mise en cause de me transmettre certains
éléments d'information à la suite de mon
entretien avec lui le 12 avril dernier
il est également important que Frédéric
oua soit présent ce matin pour répondre
aux questions de la représentation
nationale il est accompagné et je les
salue de Patrick suet secrétaire
secrétaire du conseil d'administration
et de Jean-François Mazo directeur de
société général Privet banking je vais
donc tout d'abord Monsieur Frédéric oua
vous donner la parole je vous demanderai
de vous tenir un prve propos liminire de
minutes au cours duquel il pourra vous
pourrez apporter les ers éléments
d'explication des informations parues
dans la presse et nous indiquer quelles
conséquences ont eu pour sa banque pour
la banque les mesures intervenu depuis
2009 en matière de lutte contre la
fraude et l'évasion fiscale ensuite je
vous poserai des questions
complémentaires Éric Doliger le fera
également puisqu'il est le Rapporteur
spécial sur les conventions fiscales et
tous nos collègues ici présents que je
remercie pourront vous poser bien
évidemment les questions qu'ils jugeront
utiles je vous donne la
parole merci Madame la la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs dans
le cadre de ces travaux relatifs à la
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
internationale votre commission m'invite
à m'exprimer sur la position du groupe
Société Générale alors je vous précise
que je suis accompagné donc de
Jean-François Mazo directeur de la
banque privée depuis début 2012 et de
Patrick suet secrétaire du conseil
d'administration mais Patrick était
jusqu'en septembre 2015
secrétaire général du groupe et donc
notamment en charge des questions de
conformité et des questions
fiscales les attentes des états et de
l'opinion publique sont légitimes le
groupe Société Générale et ces 145000
collaborateurs ont pleinement conscience
du rôle clé qu'il peut jouer dans le
domaine de lutte contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale c'est pourquoi je vous
je vous remercie de me donner
l'opportunité de montrer que le groupe
Société Générale exerce son métier de
banquier avec la plus grande
responsabilité et que la vision relayée
par les médias autour de des l'affaire
des Panama papers ne reflète ni la
situation actuelle ni la politique menée
par Société générale depuis plusieurs
années en matière de lutte contre la
fraude et l'évasion fiscale et laisser
penser que le groupe Société Générale
serait au cœur de l'évasion fiscale est
une information erronée et injustifiée
au regard de toutes les actions que nous
avons mené depuis plus de 5 ans les
chiffres que je vais avoir l'occasion de
partager avec vous illustre d'ailleurs
mon propos la première chose que je
voudrais souligner c'est l'ampleur des
transformations du cadre juridique et
des coopérations
internationales intervenu depuis 2009 en
matière de lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale je pense notamment aux efforts
constants des gouvernements du G20 qui
ont abouti d'abord à clarifier dès 2009
que l'échange de renseignement entre
autorités fiscales de devait primer sur
le secret
bancaire cela abouti à la mise en place
d'accords bilatéraux d'échange
d'information piloté par le CDE puis en
2014 à la mise en œuvre et la mise en
place d'un échange automatique de
renseignement avec un calendrier très
ambitieux je vous rappelle portant
d'abord sur 55 pays sur la photo 2016
avec un échange d'information en 2017
puis une deuxème vague de 43 pays
commençant sur la en 2018 sur la base de
la photo 2017 je pense également à un
aspect peut-être moins connu mais
fondamental qui est la modification des
droits nationaux pour intégrer la fraude
fiscale dans les dispositifs de lutte
contre le blanchiment suite à la
transposition de la 3e directive
européenne ça s'est fait en 2009 en
France et c'est devenu un standard
international au niveau du Gaffi en
2012 c'est dans le cadre de de ces
mutations profondes que le groupe
société général a pris un ensemble
d'initiatives d'engagement pour
s'inscrire de manière proactive dans le
soutien aux efforts des état pour lutter
contre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale
internationale alors un de ces
engagements a été de fermer les
implantations dans les États et
territoires dit non
coopératifs j'ai eu l'opportunité de
dire à à Messieurs les sénateur Dominati
et Boquet lors de mon audition du 4 mai
dernier que mes réponses aux questions
des membres de la commission d'enquête
du Sénat d'avril 2012 avait été formulé
avec la plus grande exactitude et
sincérité et j'aimerais revenir sur sur
les termes que j'ai utilisé en 2012 et
que je vais réitérer
aujourd'hui il y a deux sujets distincs
d'une part la géographie de nos
implantations implantations du groupe
Société Générale et d'autre part nos
clients avec leur diversité de
nationalité de résidence fiscale ou
d'instruments juridique avec lesquels
ils gèent leur
patrimoine ce qui concerne le premier
volet le groupe N et n'avait déjà plus
en 2012 d'implantation c'est-à-dire de
bureaux d'effectifs de revenus et de
bénéfices réalisés dans les États et
territoires non coopérativ qui
figuraient sur les listes en vigueur à
l'époque en pratique notamment en
particulier au
Panama la banque privée de Société
Générale qui est aujourd'hui la la 15e
banque privée européenne
a recentré ses activités depuis
plusieurs années principalement sur
l'Europe et est présente aujourd'hui
dans 13 pays au travers de 12 filiales
et succursales et un bureau de
représentation 13 pays qui se sont tous
engagés à faire partie de l'échange
automatique d'information et de
renseignement promulgué par l'OCDE qui
garantira une transparence fiscale en ce
qui concerne le second volet la les
relations avec nos clients et on a à peu
près 100000 clients dans le monde d'une
centain de nationalités elles sont
gérées dans ces
implantations là encore le groupe a pris
une série d'initiatives pour gérer au
mieux du point de vue de la conformité
fiscale les relations avec ses clients
et s'inscrire ainsi dans la démarche des
états alors par exemple le groupe a
adopté en fin 2010 un code de conduite
fiscale validé par le Conseil
d'Administration qui s'impose qui
s'impose à l'ensemble des activités du
groupe à l'ensemble des collaborateurs
du groupe dans le monde ce code régit
non seulement les activités et les
implantations et actions pour le compte
propre de la banque mais également les
relations avec nos clients alors d'une
manière générale le le métier de banque
privée de Société Générale fonctionne
avec des des principes de fonctionnement
transversaux le premier principe c'est
la connaissance du client en vue de
respecter nos obligations en matière de
lutte antiblanchiment et et de lutte
contre le financement du terrorisme
notamment cette connaissance du client
est matérialisée par une bonne
identification du client l'analyse de
l'origine des fonds la destination des
fonds et par l'actualisation bien sûr de
ces renseignements tout au long de la
relation d'affaires deuxièmement la
conduite de nos agents et des affaire
qui doit se faire dans le respect du
code de conduite fiscale que je
mentionnais et notamment prévoyant la
vérification la plus approfondie
possible de la conformité fiscale de nos
clients enfin l'encadrement juridique de
nos activités de banque privée dans le
respect des lois et réglementations en
vigueur dans chacun des pays dans lequel
le métier est exercé donc dans les
implantations que je mentionnais alors
venons-en maintenant plus spécifiquement
aux société patrimonial offshore une
société offshore d'abord c'est une
société immatriculée dans un pays autre
que celui de son activité économique
pays permettant notamment de les créer
facilement et un coût faible et
d'assurer la confidentialité de l'ayant
droit des raisons légitimes peuvent tout
à fait justifié de mettre en place ce
type de société comme par exemple
organiser sa transmission dans des cas
familiaux complexes ou assurer euh
protéger l'yant drroit notamment
lorsqu'il Résid dans des pays au cadre
politique au cadre juridique ou au cadre
sécuritaire non non assuré il est vrai
que la confidentialité que permettent
ces structures peut aussi conduire à
l'utilisation non conforme d'un point de
vue fiscal de cet outil mais c'est
pourquoi euh la qualité des procédures
de
conformité et de connaissance client
mise en place par la banque ainsi que la
vigilance tout au long de la vie de la
société et des services apportés est
essentielle pour garantir la conformité
au regard du droit
fiscal dans ce cadre le rôle de la
Banque peut-être de fournir ce qu'on
appelle un service fiduciaire qui
consiste notamment à créer la société
patrimoniale pour répondre à la demande
d'un client c'est-à-dire riculer cette
société l'enregistrer dans le registre
de commerce du pays concerné et assurer
sa domiciliation typiquement cette
immatriculation se fait par des
prestataires de services comme un
cabinet d'avocat type mossac fonseeka et
puis assurer la gestion administrative
de la société à savoir le dépôt des
comptes annuels l'organisation de la vie
sociale la tenue des comptes bancaires
ces services fiduciaires sont une
activité marginal au sein de la banque
privée et donc bien sûr du groupe
Société Générale tant en terme de nombre
de clients que de revenus générés et
Société Générale est particulièrement
vigilante dans la conduite de cette
activité elle est strictement encadrée
par une série de procédures en
application du code de conduite fiscale
et des instructions de lutte
antiblanchiment toute création de
société pour le compte d'un client dans
le casadre d'une prestation fiduciaire
fait l'objet d'une revue par des acteurs
indépendants du métier au sein de chaque
implantation de Société Générale acteur
de conformité dans le cadre aussi de de
la vérification fiscale qui est enoit
ont un droit de
veto Société Générale banque privée
identifie les bénéficiaires économiques
finaux de ces société offshore et
vérifie la conformité fiscale des
clients nous avons fait ainsi en 2015 70
déclarations de soupçon en lien avec les
sociétés patrimoniales offshore soit
prêtre 40 % du total des déclarations de
soupçon de la banque privée par ailleurs
la tenue de de comptte de ces sociétés
se fait à la Société générale comme je
l'ai dit dans destat dans des entités
établies dans des états comme la Suisse
le Luxembourg qui se sont engagés à
l'échange automatique
d'information il n'y a donc pas de
compte au Panama et tous les comptes de
ces sociétés patrimoniales vont faire
l'objet de l'échange automatique
d'information comme je le mentionnais
dès lors que l'ayant drroit de cette
société appartient à dans la résidence
fiscale d'un des 98 pays sé engagé dans
le processus alors nos relations avec
mossac fonsseeka et et les chiffres que
je vais vous présenter ont fait l'objet
d'un examen approfondi et indépendant de
l'inspection du groupe qui s'est déployé
dans toutes les implantations de banque
privée ces chiffres sont le résultat de
nos recherches à date et doivent être
interprété comme tel ils ont été
communiqués au régulateur français la
CPR et l'inspection a
reconstitué la série historique des
créations arrêt de relation des sociétés
créées par une entité de Société
Générale banque privée avec mossac
Fonseca l'évolution du nombre de
sociétés actives et analyser l'ensemble
des dossiers des sociétés en vie et
détenu par des résidents fiscaux
français et de l'Union
européenne alors le nombre de sociétés
patrimoniales offshore encore active et
immatriculé par mossac fonseeka pour le
compte de nos clients à la date du 30
mars 2016 est de
66 dont 6 présente la double
caractéristique d'être immatriculé au
Panama et de concer est des résidents
fiscaux français au nombre au total de
Neu je pense que ces chiffres permettent
de remettre en perspective le sujet et
le nombre de ces sociétés actives a été
divisé par près de 10 depuis
2009 tous les bénéficiaires économiques
finaux résidents fiscaux français et
européens ont fait l'objet d'une
vérification de conformité
fiscale lorsque le bénéficiaire
économique final ne parvenait pas à nous
démontrer les cette de conformité les
comptes de cette société ont été soit
fermés soit
bloqués je précise également qu'il n'y a
eu aucune ouverture de société
patrimoniale offshore immatriculé au
Panama par l'intermédiaire de mossac
fonsseca depuis 2012 à l'exception d'une
société qui a été fermé 3 mois après sa
création c'était un client en
l'occurrence résident fiscal suisse et
de nationalité belge qui nous avait
demandé de le faire puis qui finalement
décidé de pas l'utiliser donc elle a
duré 3 mois en conclusion je comprends
tout à fait que la complexité de de ce
sujet puisse conduire à une
incompréhension et à l'émotion de
l'opinion publique ces sociétés sont
légales mais l'utilisation mal encadrée
peut poser problème c'est pourquoi nous
pensons que les procédures que nous
avons mis en place en particulier dans
les conditions d'ouverture dans le
respect des règles de connaissance
client et de l'origine des fonds ainsi
que les vérification fiscales que nous
effectuons sont déterminantes pour
garantir la conformité de ces sociétés
les informations concernant les
résidents fiscaux français vous le savez
sont aujourd'hui disponibles sur demande
de l'administration fiscale auprès des
différents pays l'étape suivante que
représente la mise en place dès 2016 de
l'échange automatique d'information dans
55 pays dont les 28 pays de l'Union
européenne sera une nouvelle avancée à
mon sens majeur dans la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale notre enjeu de banquier
privé de protéger le besoin légitime de
confidentialité de C nos clients tout en
assurant évidemment la complète
transparence fiscale et bien entendu
d'une manière plus générale nous sommes
prêts à continuer à accompagner
activement la lutte contre l'évasion
fiscale je vous remercie merci Monsieur
le Directeur Général j'ai j'ai quelques
questions mais vous allez comprendre ce
sont des précisions et et sans doute
d'autres collègues auraient pu les
aborder mais moi je je voulais revenir
sur le fait de créer une société
offshore quels sont les motifs pour
lequel vous vous considérez qu'il est
légitime pour un un résident fiscal
français parlons bien de nos
compatriotes de recourir à une société
offshore quels sont les les motifs pour
lequel vous considérez que c'est
légitime euh quelles démarches doivent
être effectué par le conseiller de la
Société Générale pour s'assurer que la
structure offshore est reconnue par
l'administration fiscale du pays de
résidence du client nous allons parler
du du résident français et enfin vous
nous dites que seulement neuf résidents
français à Panama bénéficie actuellement
d'une société offshore mise en place par
mossac
Fonseca moi je vous avez on avait abordé
cette question et j'aimerais que vous le
précisiez mais y y a-t-il d'autres
cabinets que mossac fonseeka pour créer
des sociétés offshore à Panama ou
ailleurs et si oui est-ce que d'autres
résidents fiscaux français sont
concernés parmi vos clients ça me paraît
extrêmement utile d'éclairer cet aspect
voilà si vous voulez bien répondre à C à
ces trois questions et ensuite je
passerai la parole à Éric Doliger pour
la suite alors madame la Présidente je
vais prendre peut-être tout de suite la
dernière laisser Jean-François peut-être
répondre aux deux autres questions un
peu plus en détail il y a d'autres
cabinets d'avocats prestataires de
service que mossac fonsseeka au Panama
ou dans le monde en l'espèce pareil
l'inspection a fait regarder combien
nous avions de sociétés au Panama AC
avec d'autres prestataires de services
le recensement auquel nous parvenons
c'est neu sociétés concernant un
résident fiscal français qui bien
entendu a fait l'objet des mêmes
vérifications que je mentionnais donc
c'est vrai que la Société Générale a
essentiellement utilisé mossac Fonseca
au Panama mais il y a neuf pour répondre
à votre question alors d'une manière
générale comme je l'ai dit une société
offshore il faut comprendre que ça peut
répondre à des enjeux de confidentialité
notamment dans des
cas de successions d'organisation ou par
exemple si les personnes peuvent avoir
des
plusieurs plusieurs conjoints choisir
des organisations de succession qui sont
plus complexes évidemment que lorsque
vous avez une seule et même famille
c'est des questions de sécurité qui
normalement ne se pose pas en France
hein mais évidemment avec une clientèle
internationale dans certains pays y
compris à des moments de terrorisme hein
ça a pu servir à des gens pour protéger
leur patrimoine éviter des enlèvements
c'est aussi en une fois des questions
d'organisation des patrimes peut-être
que que Jean-François peut vous donner
plus d'éléments et et aussi pour
répondre à votre question sur les les
procédures en matière de contrôle fiscal
oui monsieur le directeur général sur
les autres pays on a parlé de Panama
essentiellement mais sur d'autres pays
il y a-t-il d'autres cabinets alors non
alors alors je précise nous alors on
s'est concentré d'abord sur mossac
fonsseeka parce que dans dans le temps à
parti euh mossac Fonseca les 66 pays 66
compagnies entre société pardon
patrimoniale dont je parle c'est dans
l'ensemble du monde ça c'est c'est au
mossac fonseeka dans l'ensemble du monde
c'est l'ensemble des relations que nous
pouvons avoir avec mossac foseka toute
toute immatriculation confondue si je
dire et je répète au Panama et on s'est
concentré aussi au Panama puisque je
crois que c'était en particulier l'objet
à la fois des des des articles de presse
et et de votre demande je le répète nous
avons avec d'autres prestataires neuf
sociétés complémentaires dont un
résident fiscal français euh
jean-françoisou peut-être donc pour
répondre madame la Présidente à votre
première première question c'est
pourquoi créer une une structure donc il
y a quatre grandes raisons la première
c'est la transmission et la succession
d'un patrimoine la deuxième c'est c'est
l'organisation des des avoirs la trisème
c'est la protection des biens et et des
familles et la 4è ce sont c'est le lien
avec les affaires professionnelles on on
trouve à peu près ces quatre catégories
quand il y a une création de société
offshore après quelle est la démarche
que nous
effectuons quand une création de société
offshore est envisagé alors d'abord le
code de conduite fiscale le code de
conduite fiscale qui pose des principes
liés donc au respect à la façon dont nos
agents doivent se comporter par rapport
à la façon dont ces sociétés sont créé
s'assurer que quand une société est
créée elle n'a pas pour objet de
deevenir aux lois et aux réglementations
fiscales pour
commencer s'assurer que cette société
n'a pas pour unique objet un objet
fiscal voilà deux principes importants
du code de conduite fiscale qui doivent
être respectés code de conduite qui a
été mis en place comme Frédéric oua le
rappeler en 2010 deuxème élément
important à à avoir à l'esprit nous
avons une procédure systématique dans
toutes les implantations dans lesquelles
il y a un service F fre donc on peut
créer une société comme cela est le cas
ici qui nous avons un comité qui est en
charge de vérifier si il est si nous
considérons comme acceptable pour la
Société Générale de créer une société et
dans ce comité vous avez un responsable
juridique un responsable fiscal ces
responsables juridiques et fiscaux ne
dépendent pas du métier ils sont
indépendants ils ont un droit de veto
ils PE
s'il considèrent que par
exemple l'objet de la création ne répond
pas à l'esprit du code de conduite
fiscale mettre leur véau et dans ce
cas-là soit la société n'est pas créé
soit alors on passe à une situation de
réanalyse du dossier sous un autre angle
pour voir si vous pourriez nous préciser
en fait qu'est-ce qui ne peut pas être
fait par le biais donc d'un véhicule
français puisque vous dites il y a des
cas où ils peuvent mettre un véau
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui peut faire vetau
contrevenir au
principeou si par exemple il y avait un
un client qui se présentait pour
demander à la Société Générale de créer
une société offshore dont l'objet était
par définition la la dissimulation
fiscale typiquement nous dirions non
nous n'acceptons pas d'ouvrir la société
en question et et nouvelle fois les et
Patrick su peut peut-être préciser
encore une fois les choses qu'est-ce que
sont ces départements de conformité de
fiscalité dont on vous parle comme je le
disais ce sont des départements
indépendants munis de moyens assez
considérables il faut savoir qu'il y a à
peu près 1000 pas loin de 1800 personnes
qui appartiennent au département de
conformité au niveau mondial de Société
générale ce sont des gens qui sont en
charge justement de vérifier la
conformité par rapport à des demandes
d'entrée en relation ou de d'évolution
des relations avec nos clients Patrick
su oui pour compléter sur ce point et et
répondre très précisément à votre
question comment vous vous assurez que
l'information fiscale n'est pas perdue à
cette occasion en
fait dès 2010 mais même avant mais on
l'a écrit dans le code fiscal en 2010 il
y a deux conditions pour nous la
première bien entendu on participe pas à
des opérations dont l'objet est
exclusivement fiscal mais la deuxième
c'est on s'assure mais alors très
précisément que l'administration du pays
fiscal du pays de résidence du
contribuable de la personne qui vient
nous voir cette administration fiscale
elle aura toujours accès à l'information
donc on regarde tous les chaînons de
convention fiscales qui sont opérés pour
s'assurer que s'il y avait une demande
l'information serait disponible et ça
c'est une c'est l'instruction qui avait
été donné à l'époque qui était tout
dossier pour lequel il y aurait une
coupure dans la transmission possible
d'information serait refusé et c'est
notre c'est la doctrine que l'on
applique alors aujourd'hui avec
l'échange automatique d'information bien
entendu pour nous ça va être beaucoup
plus simple à appliquer cette règle
puisque on aura un dispositif encore
mieux construit qu'auparavant mais c'est
ce que nous faisons depuis 2010 et et
peutre pour vraiment bien vous rappeler
que cet échange automatique
d'information donc par exemple si vous
prenez un résident fiscal français qui
travaillerait avec nous au Luxembourg et
qui aurait une société offshore euh y
compris au Panama sur la photo 2016
c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui ils sera
déclaré à l'administration fiscale du
Luxembourg en 2017 et cette information
sera automatiquement transmise à
l'administration fiscale française dans
le cas de la Suisse qui appartient à la
deuxè vague c'est la même chose mais
décalé d'un
an tous les comptes seront déclarés pour
un résident fiscal en Suisse pris sur la
photo 2017 transmis en 2018 à
l'administration fiscale Suisse et
automatiquement communiqué à
l'administration fiscale
française
merci pour cette première série de
réponses Éric Doliger va vous poser
quelques questions supplémentaire oui
merci madame la Présidente oui je vais
me permettre de poser quelques questions
au nom du rapporteur général albéric de
Montgolfier qui n'a pas pu être avec
nous donc vous venez de dire il y a
quelques instants Monsieur le Directeur
général quand quelqu'un nous demande de
créer une société offshore alors ma
première question va être sur ce sujetl
la semaine dernière le chef du service
du contrôle fiscal nous a indiqué qu'il
est très rare qu'un client ait de
lui-même l'idée de mettre en place des
montages impliquant le recours à une
société écran alors la création d'une
société offshore répond-t-elle toujours
à une demande précise du client peut-il
s'agir d'une initiative de la Société
Générale voilà ma première question la
deuxième les obligations de vigilance
sont elles les mêmes quel que soit
l'état dans lequel est implantée la
filiale de la Société générale dont le
client utilise une société offshore y
compris par exemple lorsque le
blanchiment de fraude fiscale n'est pas
incriminé donc vous nous avez dit tout à
l'heure je crois que vous aviez 13 pays
dans lequel vous étiez implanté qui tous
relevaiit de l'échange automatique mais
il serait intéressant que vous nous
précisiez cela et puis il y a une date
que vous avez cité bien sûr qui est
depuis 2012 hein puisque vous avez dit
depuis 2012 on n'est plus à Panama et on
s'est recentré dans un certain nombre de
pays et euh le 24 octobre 2012 la
société générale a été sanctionné par la
CPR pour les carences affectant son
dispositif de contrôle de la conformité
de l'activité banque privé à la suite de
cette sanction le dispositif de contrôle
a-t-il été renforcé et puis un petit
point que que je rajouterai à titre
personnel vous nous avez dit il y a
quelques
instants on a un code de conduite et on
fait attention à ce que la personne qui
vient nous voir lorsqu'elle souhaite une
société offshore n'est pas pour unique
objet l'aspect
fiscal donc vous avez dit n'est pas pour
unique objet alors bien évidemment j'ai
bien noté qu'il y avait l'organisation
des avoirs les successions protéger les
enroit la confidentialité et cetera mais
vous nous avez dit pas pour unique objet
l'aspect fiscal est-ce que cela veut
dire qu'on peut vous apporter d'autres
objets qui camoufle un peu l'aspect
fiscal Monsieur le Directeur Général oui
alors je vais essayer de répondre
peut-être pas totalement dans l'ordre et
et le caséchéant me tourner vers mes
deux collègues sur peut-être la la la
sanction à CPR c'est une mission qui a
été conduite qui a fait une qui s'est
déroulée en 2010
euh sur tris ou qure mois et qui portait
effectivement donc sur la banque privée
en France euh hein je parle surous le
contrôle de Patrick suet donc une banque
privée assez différente hein dans la
nature des clients et qui avait fait un
certain nombre de recommandations et
d'observations sur le dispositif
effectivement de contrôle de conformité
depuis effectivement les moyens ont été
sensiblement renforcés je parle de
mémoire je vous citais les près de 1800
personnes travaillant dans le
département conformité aujourd'hui de la
Société Générale le chiffre a été à peu
près doublé sur la période justement à
peu près 2010 2016 donc on a des
renforcés considéra les moyens également
d'ailleurs dans les équipes de fiscalité
euh
sur les les obligations de de de
vigilance et le droit alors là aussi
peut-être que Patrick peut entrer un peu
plus dans détail mais c'est vrai que
vous avez une évolution comme je l'avis
mentionné dans mon intervention
préliminaire à la fois de la
coordination internationale et des
droits applicables dans un certain
nombre de pays et par exemple y compris
en France le blanchiment a été introduit
dans les aspects de lutte pardon la
fraude fiscale a été introduite dans les
aspects de de conformité en matière de
de d'antiblanchiment en 2009
euh c'est devenu un standard
international et ça a été introduit
alors c'est introduit par la Suisse en
2016 et le Luxembourg a prévu de le
faire en 2017 donc vous voyez que il y a
une espèce d'harmonisation
progressive des droits qui se fait à un
rythme variable d'un pays à l'autre
ce que nous nous avons essayé de faire
c'est ce que je mentionnais à travers
ces règles transversales c'est à la fois
bien sûr de respecter les droits
nationaux mais d'établir des règles
communes de fonctionnement applicaes à
toutes les entités se traduisant
notamment par le code de conformité
fiscale qu'on mentionnait et des
processus d'ouverture des structures que
là aussi nous avons rappelé qui sont
identiques dans les entités les les
fameux comités qui regardent les
ouvertures en question avec des
responsables de conformité de fiscalité
qui dépendent je le répète
hiérarchiquement d'un patron à Paris et
pas du métier donc il n'ont pas comme
incitation de les ouvrir au au au risque
de faire peser un un risque à la Société
générale c'est quelque chose qu'on a
déployer partout j'ajoute si vous voulez
j'ajoute dans dans ce processus
d'évolution que vous
mentionnez que si si je reprends
l'évolution du métier Société générale
il y a deux grandes phases c'est un
métier assez jeune à à la Société
générale c'est un un métier qui s'est
structuré à partir de
1996 et juste pour vous mentionner c'est
ça représente 3 % des revenus de la
Société Générale aujourd'hui il y a une
première phase début des années 2000
jusqu'à la fin des des années 2000 de
construction de ce métier qui s'est fait
à la fois par la croissance organique
mais aussi par une série d'acquisitions
par exemple on a acquis une banque
privée en Suisse on s'est renforcé en
Suisse en
2003 phase de développement
puis à partir du début des années
2010 pour plein de raisons y compris les
impératifs stratégiques qui pesaient sur
les banques dans la foulée de la crise
financière imposant de se
refocaliser mais aussi cont tenu
justement des changements de de de
l'environnement juridique et de la
nécessité de renforcer les les les
processus de conformité et de contrôle
on s'est recentré sur un nombre de pays
plus limité donc phase de développement
recentrage quelques exemples de ce
recentrage on a cédé notre activité de
banque privée au Japon nous avons cédé
en en
2014 des fonds de commerce que nous
avions en Asie donc on a cédé nos
clients asiatiques en Asie à une banque
singapourienne nous sommes sortis et
également des États-Unis et une nouvelle
fois pour essayer et c'est en cela que
j'insiste moi sur sur ce cette double
dimension implantation relation client
on s'est reconcentré dans des pays qui
vont faire l'objet de l'échange
automatique d'information on a concentré
aussi nos expertises dans un certain
nombre de pays y compris le le service
fiduciaire que je mentionnais pour les
sociétés offshore c'est dans deux pays
que ça se fait tout ça avec l'idée de se
dire il est important de vérifier la la
robustesse des processus et que
l'application soit la plus solide
possible concentrons-nous donc et et je
pense personnellement que d'un point de
vue stratégique une nouvelle fois cet
élément de de d'échange automatique
d'information est est fondamental
fondamental que ce soit pour des via des
sociétés offshore ou plus normalement
via des comptes donc bien comprendre et
et du coup je crois que avec cet échange
automatique cette convergence des droits
nationaux et et nous moi je suis plus il
y aura une harmonisation des droits plus
il sera facile d'exercer notre métier de
banque privée ça c'est totalement
évident mais cette harmonisation est
encore en cours on a essayé si vous
voulez de combiner le mieux possible le
respect des droits nationaux et parfois
des contraintes de ces droits nationaux
avec des règles transversales et je
dirais je pense qu'on va continuer à
faire des progrès à travers les les
progrès qui se matérialisent encore
comme je mentionnis en Suisse c'est
Luxembourg alors sur peut-être les
sujets de de de client il faut quand
même avoir en tête que la la la la
plupart de ces clients sont des clients
avec un patrimoine assez diversifié qui
ont plusieurs conseils qui ont même
parfois ce qu'on appelle dans le jargon
du métier des family office c'est-à-dire
des structures de gens qui les aident à
à gérer ses patrimoines peut-être que
Jean-François peut peut peut illustrer
un peu le type de client et ce sont des
gens qui sont capables d'avoir de
l'expertise venant en dehors de la
banque d'ailleurs ce sont des clients
très souvent multibancarisés il faut
surtout pas avoir l'idée en général que
on concentrerait la totalité des voir
ces clients parce que leur patrimoine
est souvent international ont plusieurs
banques tu peux peut-être élaborer sur
ce thème de même que sur ce la question
de monsieur le sénateur sur l'unique
objet est-ce que des objets pourrait
cacher des des objets
fiscaux alors peut-être sur le donc sur
le la raison pour laquelle donc des
clients peuvent utiliser société
offshore on en a parlé tout à
l'heure je crois que pour ce qui
concerne la banque l'action qui est la
nôtre c'est de faire du conseil
patrimonial le conseil patrimonial vise
à nouveau à regarder avec nos clients
les sujets qui ont trait à des questions
on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure de
succession de
transmission la solution peut-être dans
certains cas la mise en place d'une
société d'une société qui peut être qui
peut-être offshore peut-être onshore
d'ailleurs c'est une des solutions mais
tout ceci encore une fois est encadré et
doit faire l'objet de toutes les
vérifications que j'ai mentionné tout à
l'heure ça n'est pas l'unique
je dirais fonction de nos conseillers
patrimoniaux nos conseillers
patrimoniaux comme le disait Frédéric ou
tout à l'heure il parle à des clients ou
à des
prospects selon des règles très précises
d'ailleurs dans les pays dans lesquels
nous sommes avec des règles de ce qu'ils
peuvent dire pas dire comment tout ceci
est encadré par des
procédures mais ils ne sont pas les
seuls à avoir ce dialogue avec des
ces clients la plupart du temps ont un
conseiller fiscal un conseiller
juridique ont effectivement dans un
certain nombre de cas donc une structure
qui les aide à faire des choix qui sont
des choix patrimoniaux qui sont des
choix financiers donc ce dialogue se
nourrit autour de plusieurs acteurs nous
sommes un des acteurs parfois la
solution est une solution de type
société offshore parfois c'est autre
chose ça dépend véritablement des
situations on a des on a de grandes
variétés de situations auqu on doit
faire face en tout état de cause c'est
toujours la même règle qui s'applique
c'està-dire que quand une société
offshore vient à être
proposé pour nos clients dans le cadre
du conseil patrimonial nous passons par
la procédure de ce comité qui va la
regarder sous ces différents angles et
qui va se prononcer en
indépendance voilà pour répondre dernier
point c'est ce comité qui essaie
justement de voir si un motif ah ou bien
sûr une
dissimulationation c'était votre point
monsieur le sénateur absolument c'est si
si euh ce comité venait à détecter cela
évidemment euh que l'opération est
rejetée c'est absolument clair c'est la
façon dont on fonctionne euh et euh
évidemment dans les dans les pays dans
lesquels euh euh la déclaration de
soupçon euh sur l'objet euh de du
soupçon de fraude fiscale euh est
possible nous serions amenés à faire une
déclaration de
soupçon peut-être Jean-François Mazo
vous pourriez
entrer un tout petit peu plus dans le le
le détail de la procédure interne qu'on
a mise en place pour vérifier ces
aspects fiscaux parce que je je à
travers les questions vous interrogez
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'on regarde
comment on essaie de de s'assurer que il
y a pas de volonté de dissimulation vous
pouvez peut-êtreir un peu alors oui
alors il av parce qu'il y av a une
partie de la question qui était qui
avait très je pense à la connaissance de
nos clients hein donc ça c'est quand
même je dirais quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important qui a progressé
dans le temps mais sur lequel nous avons
une responsabilité particulière il
s'agit d'abord de les
identifier donc précisément d'identifier
l'origine des fonds de ces clients de
voir quelle est la finalité de
l'opération au-delà de la finalité
fiscale il peut y avoir d'autres
finalités il faut s'assurer que cette
finalité soit
convenable il faut aussi dans le cadre
de la vie d'un compte regarder les
mouvements voir s'il y a des choses
anormales ça fait partie de notre métier
de banquier et
évidemment regarder la question de la
conformité fiscale et s'assurer de la la
conformité fiscale de nos clients donc
ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui c'est
que nous mettons en place donc
une une analyse systématique de nos
nouveaux clients nous questionnons en
fait la conformité fiscale des avoirs et
de nos clients et nous avons
engagé à ce titre une action en deux
temps un premier temps en 2013 qui a
consisté à rappeler à nos clients dans
nos implantations à
l'étranger leurs obligations en matière
de conformité fiscale donc nous avons à
ce à cet
effet
préciser les conditions générales de nos
implantations elles peuvent être
consultées vous verrez c'est très
explicite nous
avons formalisé les choses et nous avons
informé nos
clients deuxième temps nous nous
assurons
euh non seulement de la bonne
information des clients mais également
que le stock des clients de la Société
Générale est conforme fiscalement et
donc nous avons une opération qui est en
cours en deux vagues qui a démarré en
2015 et qui se prolonge en 2016 et qui
vise à regarder requestionner la
conformité fiscale de la totalité de
notre fond de
commerce donc nous nous nousous reposons
la question et nous faisons cet exercice
chaque fois que un nouveau client
évidemment se se se
présente une question complémentaire un
peu mais qui qui retrouve la même chose
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner un
cas concret
sans trahir les noms bien sûr euh pour
lequel la Société Générale
recommanderait un résident fiscal
français de créer une société offshore
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner un
exemple ou deux exemples si vous le
pouvez je m bien pas à l'esprit
immédiatement
mais ça pourrait éclairer un peu en en
en négatif
et peut-être non mais ceci peut arriver
sur des grands des grands patrimoines
internationaux avec par exemple
quelqu'un qui aurait un un portefeuille
d'immeuble euh au Brésil c'est pas
absolument anormal qu'il puisse créer
une société dans un pays qui n'est pas
la France pour détenir ce ce patrimoine
si les conditions juridiques économiques
fiscales le permettent voilà c'est le
type et c'est souvent le le cas de
figure qu'on a c'estd qu'on a ces
sociétés elles servent à isoler des des
des morceaux de patrimoine qui ont soit
un mode de gestion homogène soit sont
destinés à telle partie de la famille
lorsqu'il s'agit de d'organiser une
succession ou s'il s'agit d'opérations
qui sont liées à des patrimoines
industriels répondre à une stratégie de
l'entreprise que détient le le le client
que l'on
rencontre je voulais juste aussi
peut-être revenir toujours monsieur
sénateur sur votre question ce ce droit
parce que j'ai lu tous les articles de
presse et a souvent l'idée on ne connaît
pas finalement qui détient la structure
euh juste souligner que si en ce qui
concerne par exemple la fraude fiscale
l'introduction dans les aspects de lutte
antiblanchiment peuvent être récents
comme je l'ai dit par exemple en Suisse
en revanche en Suisse tout ce qui
concerne les autres éléments de
connaissance du client ce qu'on appelle
unti money landering AML était en
revanche et sont très strictes et relève
du droit pénal et ne peuvent pas être
délégués par exemple à quelqu'un d'autre
que la banque que je dire par là c'est
que dans ce paysage
juridique l'identification et dans les
pays en tout cas dans lequel on fait
notre activité l'identification des
ayant droit le fait que les fonds ne
viennent pas de source indépendamment du
sujet fiscal mais de source très très
condamnable existe voilà juste pour
terminer la la photo un peu de ce
paysage juridique
je donner la parole à Éric Boquet
maintenant qui va vous
questionner bien merci Madame la
Président je pense qu'à ce stade il
convient de rappeler Monsieur le
Directeur Général pourquoi vous êtes
ici vous avez été reçu par Monsieur
sapin ministre de l'économie il y a un
mois vous avez rencontré Madame la
Présidente de la Commission ici la
semaine
suivante monsieur Dominati moi-même nous
avons rencontré le 4 mai dernier et vous
êtes ce matin devant la commission des
finances et vous n'êtes pas là par
hasard il s'agit pas d'une audition tout
à fait ordinaire euh c'est pas elle
n'était pas prévu il y a un mois cette
audition elle a lieu parce qu'il s'est
passer des choses c'est pas on parle pas
de l'évasion fiscale de manière générale
on parle de votre cas particulier et je
vais rappeler ici quelle été l'élément
déclencheur vous avez été auditionné le
17 avril 2012 par une commission
d'enquête dont Monsieur Dominati était
le président et moi-même le
rapporteur vous avez vous êtes intervenu
sous serment c'est le la règle pour une
commission d'enquête vous avez validé le
compte-rendu qui vous a été adressé et
qui figure aujourd'hui au rapport des
commissions d'enquête en question et
nous nous sommes revus donc le 4 mai
dernier vous avez confirmé les propos
que vous aviez tenu à l'époque je vais
me permettre de les rappeler ici c'est
pas très
long la Société Générale a fermé ses
implantations dans les pays qui
figuraient sur cette liste grise mais
aussi dans ceux que désignaient la liste
des États non coopératif c'est-à-dire en
pratique pour nous à Panama c'est vous
qui avez cité le pays Panama un peu plus
loin vous dites nous n'avons plus
d'activité ni dans les pays de la liste
grise ni dans les États non coopératifs
et nous avons été au-delà de ces
exigences en fermant nos activités dans
les territoires qui ne figuraient pas
sur ces deux listes mais qui étaient
considérés comme des centres financier
offshore fin de citation et puis il y a
eu les révélations de ce consortium
international de journalist
d'investigation début avril je vais
juste citer un article publié dans le
monde dans l'édition du 7 avril 979
sociétés offshore ouvertes par la banque
chez mossac Fonseca dont une partie sont
toujours actives ces entités ont été
ématriculées entre 2000 et 2010 au
Panama dans les îles viierges
britanniques et au séchel pour des
clients fortunés depuis ses filiales au
Luxembourg en Suisse et au Bahamas elle
place la Société générale dans le top 5
des banques clientes de la firme
panaméenne fin de citation donc voilà
l'élément déclencheur ce qui a valu que
notre groupe fasse un rappel au
règlement dans l'hémicycle de ce Sénat
au lendemain des
révélations et nous avons par la voix de
notre présidente de groupe Ian Assassi
transmis un courrier au bureau du Sénat
afin de le saisir pour qu'il soit statué
sur la situation créée par le
télescopage entre vos déclarations de
2012 et les révélations faites par la
presse voilà pour le contexte
général j'aurais effectivement quelques
questions à vous poser nousous sommes vu
donc la semaine dernière à
hlos dans
cette audition dans cette rencontre j'ai
eu l'occasion d'évoquer l'existence de
votre filiale au Bermude en me référant
à un article des échos daté du 1er
juillet
2014 filiale au bermud qui réalise
d'après le journal un chiffre d'affaires
de 17 millions d'euros avec aucun
salarié ce à quoi vous avez répondu il
s'agit d'une société de réassurance sur
les berm mude et j'en reviens aux
déclarations de 2012 où vous dites avoir
quitté les pays figurant sur la liste
grise de l'OCDE à l'époque il y en avait
38 et parmi ces pays figurit bien les
Bermudes donc voilà ma première question
la deuxème question
979 sociétés offshore si on cite le
monde vous en avez contesté le nombre en
disant nous n'avons jamais eu autant de
sociétés mais vous n'avez pas contesté
l'existence de ces société seul le
nombre a été contesté par vous à cette
occasion donc vous admettez en creux
qu'effectivement il y a des sociétés qui
qui vous
concerernent 3ème
aspect vous avez mis en parallèle les
termes implantation et
activité en les considérant comme des
synonymes je pense pas que implantation
et activité soi exactement des synonim
mais je pense même que ce sont des mots
très différents et la deuxième question
que j'avais posé à la commission
d'enquête à l'époque portait bien sur
les activités et donc des clients de
votre banque ayant ouvert des sociétés
depuis une filiale que j'évoquerai après
doit être considéré à mon avis comme une
activité 4e point je suis surpris que
vous n'évoquiez pas le votre filiale au
Luxembourg Société Générale Bank and
Trust Luxembourg qui est pointé dans
l'opération Panama papers comme étant
ayant été le bras armé de ces opérations
de création de société donc je suis un
peu étonné que vous n'ayez pas cé cette
filiale c'est votre groupe et je pense
qu'elle a sans doute des explications à
fournir sur la situation qui a été
créée 5è point vous avez dit à un moment
donné ce matin peut-être pas mais dans
les précédentes auditions ou dans la
presse que les sociétés avaient été
créées par des clients mais ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure le fameux
principe du KYC le know your customer
vous devez connaître vos clients et ça
induit des obligations fortes qui ont
été rappelées que je vais rappeler
qui interdit d'entretenir une quelconque
relation d'affaires avec un client dont
l'identité la provenance et la
destination des fonds et opérations ne
sont pas assez connus pour offrir des
garanties des garanties appréciables
contre leur caractère illicite donc
connaître ses clients c'est une
obligation en plus vous êtes redevenu
vous l'étiez déjà en 2012 le président
de la Fédération bancaire française mais
par système de rotation vous êtes
redevenu et donc ça vous implique
doublement sur le respect des règles
prudentielles dans la gestion des
comptes des clients donc voilà les C
questions que je voulais poser en
premier lieu et dernier point qui a été
évoqué dans l'audition du 4 mai vous
avez dit que effectivement il existait
d'autres cabinets madame la Présidente a
pointé cette question et vous aviez dit
qu'il en existait C je crois est-ce que
vous pourriez nous citer la liste
nominative des cabinets que vous aviez
en tête lors de l'audition du 4 mai
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire pour
l'instant Monsieur le Directeur Général
alors Monsieur le Directeur Général
monsieur le sénateur je suis un peu
embarrassé parce que vous revenez sur
une procédure que le Sénat m'a demandé
de respecter concernant le point qui
était l'accusation en quelque sorte de
de faux témoignages dont j'ai fait
l'objet je parle sous le contrôle du
président Dominati au cours de cette
audition du 4 j'ai eu l'occasion de
revenir très en détail sur l'ensemble de
mes déclarations et de confirmer comme
vous le savez que j'avais répondu avec
la plus grande sincérité au question
alors je ne sais pas si c'est le lieu de
reprendre exactement le texte vous
mentionnez des petits bouts je préfère
peut-être me tourner à la limite vers le
président sinon on va passer peut-être
trop de temps demander à Philippe
dominetti de de d'intervenir à ce
moment-là puisque vous étiez oui bien
sûr madame la Présidente pour informer
mes mes collègues de la commission des
finances sur le point particulier
qu'évoquait mon collègue Éric boet parce
que en réalité il y a un débat général
et il y avait l'existence d'une
commission d'enquête en 2012 devant
laquelle monsieur ouea en double qualité
à la fois de président de la Fédération
française des banques et de la Société
Générale avait porté un un témoignage et
avait été
auditionné selon la procédure je dirais
interne du
Sénat le président Larcher nous a
proposé à Monsieur boket moi-même il y a
déjà quelques temps à peu près vers le
le 10 avril ou le le 12 avril une
procédure qui avait été
d'ailleurs usité au Sénat pour une autre
commission d'enquête dans des cas à peu
près comparable quant à la vécité des
propos qu'un auditeur peut tenir devant
une commission d'enquête euh à
l'époque Monsieur boet avait demandé
quelques jours de réflexion et puis
après réflexion avait euh rejeter cette
procédure et puis donc il me restait moi
à me déterminer en tant qu'ancien
président de commission d'enquête pour
me faire ma libre opinion sur les propos
qui étaient tenus euh j'ai demandé avoir
monsieur oua mercredi dernier je crois
en tout cas dans courant de la semaine
dernière monsieur bet a écrit au
président du Sénat pour participer à
cette audition avec moi je dirais la la
veille de
l'audition une question a été posée par
Monsieur bet je crois que j'ai posé une
vingtaine de questions pour me faire mon
opinion et une audition assez complète
j'ai transmis bien évidemment
euh la totalité de cette audition et mon
sentiment au président du Sénat
vous-même au rapporteur général du
budget je crois que Monsieur boet en a
fait de même de son côté je je dirais en
ce qui concerne l'audition de l'époque
pour moi il n'y a pas de doute et
j'aurais aimé que des questions précises
proviennent de la part de mon collègue
au cours de l'audition de Monsieur ouea
parce que monsieur ouea a réservé un
certain nombre d'informations pour la
commission des finances moi j'ai essayé
de faire ma libre opinion au cours de
cette audition qui a duré à peu près
1hure 1h3 j'ai eu la réponse à un
certain nombre de questions des
questions complémentair ont été formulé
dans l'exposé que vient de faire
monsieur oua mais en ce qui concerne le
témoignage et la prise sous serment je
dirais l'engagement du serment devant la
commission j'ai fait part de mon
sentiment au président du Sénat après
une très longue audition et je ne vois
rien qu'il puisse amener le bureau du
Sénat à poursuivre sur cette déclaration
monsieur
ouea sur son témoignage de 2012 je le
dis publiquement puisque
je dirais le cas particulier a été
évoqué par Monsieur boet je pense avoir
posé des questions assez précises j'ai
eu des réponses précises de la part de
Monsieur oua on en a dans le débat
autour de cette commission donc sur le
cas particulier pour moi il y a une
procédure ça sera au bureau du Sénat de
trancher il y a des avis manifestement
divergent entre monsieur boet et
moi-même mais effectivement ça n'avait
pas à mon sens à être abordé ici puisque
nous avons travaillé pour faire une
procédure je dirais parallèle sur le
passé là nous parlons du présent et de
l'avenir maintenant si on parle du passé
je je tiens à dire ce qu'il en est à ce
stade de la
procédure clair alors par contre
j'aurais bien
aimé alors je reprendrai la parole plus
tard sur sur d'autres sujets sur les
sujets il y aura d'autres sujets
d'accord bien Monsieur le Directeur
Général merci monsieur le sénateur donc
sans revenir sur ce point je voudrais
juste parce que je dois doit apporter
des réponses vous me dites sur les
Bermudes les Bermudes ne faisaient pas
partie de la liste des
ETNC de l'État français nous avons une
filiale au Bermude non non mais même de
l'OCDE alors oui bon je crois qu'il faut
être très
précis l'engagement pris par la
Fédération française des banques était
de sortir de la liste grise de
l'OCDE et nous avons pris en ce qui
concerne socité générale le même
engagement je vous ai donné monsieur
monsieur oua vous a donné la semaine
dernière cette liste dans cette liste il
n'y a pas les Bermudes puisque il y a
deux sortes de liste il y a la liste des
pays qui ont amélioré leur situation
dans lequel il y a les Bermudes et la
France exactement au même niveau
d'ailleurs et il y a les pays qui n'ont
pas amélioré et c'est celle-là la liste
grise et dans cette liste il n'y a pas
les Bermude en revanche il y avait par
exemple vous citez il a Panama qui était
dans la liste d'où le le fait qu'on se
soit engagé et que nous sommes sortis de
Panama de la même manière il y avait
d'autres centres financiers pour lequel
la Fédération bancaire n'avait pas pris
d'engagement et pour lequel en revanche
nous nous avons décidé volontairement de
sortir bruneil et les Philippines et au
total nous sommes donc sortis de
l'ensemble des pays que la France avait
classé en début
2010 territoire non coopérative donc il
doit pas y avoir de confusion sur les
listes parce que si nous nous aurions dû
sortir des Bermudes alors il aurait
fallu qu'on quitte la France Monsieur
bet alors ensuite euh je précise par
ailleurs que les Bermudes en
l'occurrence sont imposées en France
hein euh l'activité en question est
imposée au France par application euh du
régime
209b alors ensuite euh vous me dites je
mentionne pas le Luxembourg si enfin je
je il me semble que je l'ai mentionné
j'ai cité même un exemple de résident
fiscal français euh qui pourrait avoir
euh un compte socié offshore au
Luxembourg je je mentionnais que il va
faire l'objet de la déclaration
automatique oui le Luxembourg fait
partie des 13 pays dans lesquels nous
avons encore une filiale une succursale
ou un bureau de représentation au
Luxembourg je précise d'ailleurs que
nous n'avons pas que des activités de
banque privée nous avons aussi des
métiers de titre c'est une place
importante hein pour le métier titre au
niveau européen euh voilà donc je je je
je le répète nous avons une activité
auction mais qui suit exactement toutes
les règles que que nous vous avons
mentionné ensuite
euh société par des clients je je je je
dis société créé à la demande des
clients ensuite l'immatriculation ce que
nous faisons nous comme on l'a dit dans
le service fiduciaire c'est que nous
nous adressons un prestataire de service
du type cabinet d'avocat mossac fonseeka
qui lui va immatriculer enregistrer et
CEA faire ces démarches administrativ
que que nous n'avons pas la la capacité
à faire dernier point à vous mentionner
alors en l'occurrence puisque je répète
nous avons une inspection qui qui essaie
de
reconstituer le le le chiffre de 5 et
donc 9 je je reconirmais aujourd'hui le
nombre de sociétés panaméennes avec
d'autres prestataire de service c'est
neuf dont un résident fiscal français et
très honnêtement je n'ai pas en
l'occurrence les noms des prestataires
en
question de toute façon il a été bien
indiqué il y a une procédure qui est
envisager vers le bureau du Sénat qui va
je pense suivre un cours logique qui
n'est pas effectivement totalement celui
qui est concerné ce matin nous sommes
sur un un espace plus vaste et vous
l'avez compris donc d'autres collègues
demande je remercie Éric boet je
remercie Philippe dominti pour cette ces
informations et je vais donner la parole
à marc Laménie maintenant
oui merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
merci Monsieur le Directeur Général et
vos et vos
collègues de de de de toute les les les
les informations sur des sujets je
dirais qui sont quand même extrêmement
compliqués et puis on on se on se met à
la place aussi nous représentants des
des collectivités territoriales et de
dans nos départements respectif
euh bon on connaît la Société générale
comme très modeste clients et les
clients de l'autre côté c'est c'est
quand même il y a il y a un il y a un
très grand décalage entre les les petits
clients dans nos départements respectifs
qui font confiance à leur conseiller
financiers donc localement puis de
l'autre côté B au monde je
dirais presque je dis pas presque
virtuel au quatre coins du monde avec
des des sociétés si on parle au petits
clients de la Société Générale mon père
y était euh bon on prend bon on peut
avoir des des des des cas personnels je
dirais avec euh des des biens très
limités des comptes très limité en terme
financier puis de l'autre côté j'irais
des des millions des millions d'euros ou
autres euh et et et puis alors après au
modeste client quand on parle de société
offshore et tout ça c'est vrai que il
faut se mettre à la place du modeste
client et et et de l'autre côté il y a
de tels décalages je dirais qui nous
interpelle
complètement et dans lequel on s'y perd
réellement alors là nous comme membre de
la commission des finances je dirais
qu'on essaie de d'avoir d'être éclairé
essayer de comprendre les choses la
réalité des choses la vérité des choses
aussi euh dans dans un souci de de
rigueur c'est c'est vrai on est quand
même complètement un peu interpellé
alors simplement moi ma ma question ça
serait je
dirais les toutes ces toutes ces
sociétés qui sont ou filial au au quatre
coin du au qure coin du monde je dirais
est-ce qu'on a une idée une idée parce
que on raisonne sur le budget de l'État
euh est-ce qu'on peut parler quand même
d'une certaine forme de de manque à
gagner parce que on parle de fraude
fiscale on parle euh donc de l'autre
côté je dirais bah des des des personnes
qu' ont réellement des grands des grands
moyens des fortunes ou autre
bon après quelle est quelle est quand
même cette interprétation de manque à
gagner en terme parce qu'on a beau avoir
l'administration fiscale
et les serviteurs de l'État qui font au
mieux mais mais réellement il y a quand
même beaucoup de choses qui nous
échappent et qui leur échappent aussi il
faut le dire donc on essaie de
quantifier de raisonner en en terme
financiers voilà merci merci mes chers
collègues si vous voulez bien Monsieur
le Directeur général je vous propose de
prendre une série de trois collègues
peut-être parce que les questions
risquent de se recouper donc je vais
donner la parole tout de suite à Richard
Jong ensuite à Michel
Bouvard merci madame la Présidente trois
trois
questions vous comprenez quand même
notre malaise vis-à-vis de ce système
des sociétés offshore j''yarrive vous
nous avez donné quatre raisons certaines
sont d'ailleurs à la limite de la
moralité mais enfin ça nous ne
mélangerons pas les valeurs morales et
les
activités et au fond on se dit tout ça
n'apporte pas grand-chose à l'économie
entre autres à l'économie française ou
européenne on se demande au fond à quoi
ça sert à un moment où où nous
menons-nous un certain nombre de
d'observations et de discussions pour
obliger les grandes sociétés américaines
à payer leurs impôts sur le lieu de
leurs activités en France et en Europe
donc on a là une difficulté que vous
devez
comprendre alors bien sûr c'est pas dans
notre pouvoir de supprimer le statut
offshore qui doit dépendre du droit de
chaque pays
j'imagine mais en même
temps je crois qu'on peut dire
que ça devrait pas être quelque chose
d'encouragé voilà c'est pas quelque
chose qui apporte au pays à notre pays
ou ou à l'Europe en dehors même de la
partie fraude fiscale qui elle est
directement malintentionné mais pour le
reste au fond c'est pas très très utile
et je pense en plus au cas cas de Panama
c'est que vous avez indiqué avoir réglé
mais à Panama vous le savez simpement
mieux que moi souvent les titres étaient
au porteur c'est-à-dire que personne ne
savait en fait qui étaient les
propriétaires même pas d'ailleurs les
autorités panaméennes c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui nous disait puisque nous nous
avions eu un débat ici où le Sénat avec
beaucoup de sagesse avait refusé de
ratifier la convention fiscale avec
Panama bon ensuite les choses ont évol
mais on avait quand même senti que
c'était pas bien donc je voulais vous
interroger là-dessus je voulais vous
demander
aussi c'est plus concernant la Société
Générale qui est la deuxè banque
française donc vous avez 140000 1500000
emplois vous êtes un grand
employeur qu'est-ce qui fait au fond que
la Société Générale apparaît plus que
les autres les autres banques françaises
je veux dire dans dans ce cette histoire
des Panama papers euh est-ce que les
autres sont beaucoup plus vertueux ou
est-ce qu'il y a une explication de
votre stratégie des
années des années précédentes est-ce que
vous pouvez pouvez l'expliquer voilà je
m'arrêterai là Michel Bouvard merci
madame la
Présidente je voudrais revenir sur sur
le sujet Panama mais peut-être plus en
illustration pour comprendre euh les
fonctionnements vous avez créé au niveau
de la Société Générale deux fondations
qui sont au Panama pour qu'on comprenne
bien les choses est-ce que dans le casre
de ces fondations est-ce qu'elles sont
détenues par les clients est-ce qu'elles
sont détenues par la Société Générale et
quel
type de contrôle peut être exercé par la
Société Générale sur ces structures
est-ce que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure monsieur le Président les les
services FID fiduciaire est-ce que
lorsqu'il y a une fondation est-ce qu'il
y a service fiduciaire automatiquement
ou non est-ce que il y a un
accompagnement sur la qualité des
procédures de de conformité quel est le
lien au bout du bout qui existe entre
les fondations et la Société Générale et
puis d'une manière générale peut-être
prolongeant ce qui vient d'être évoqué
par Richard Jung lorsqu'un client
demande la mise en place d'une société
euh vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure
évidemment le le fait qu'il y a cette
activité de banque privée mais que ces
sociétés finalement représentent une
faible part de chiffre d'affaires la
Société générale dans certains cas vous
l'avez rappelé peut voir confier un
mandat financière dans d'autres cas se
contenter d'une mise en relation d'un
client avec un cabinet d'avocat par
exemple mossac
fonsseeka quelle est la la différence
dans le rôle de la Société générale dans
dans ces deux figure et euh qu'est-ce
qui en résulte finalement en terme de
rémunération pour la banque qu'est-ce
qui en résulte en terme d'intérêt à
moyen et à long terme pour votre groupe
et puis peut-être une toute dernière
question vous avez évoqué les 70
déclarations de soupçon qui ont été
faites en 2015 euh quel est est-ce qu'on
peut avoir des des informations sur la
la typologie euh des soupçons qui ont
motivé ces déclarations et est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui sur ces 70 déclarations
de soupçon est-ce qu'il y a des queles
sont quelles suites ont été données par
l'administration que vous avez
saisi merci à nos trois collègues
Monsieur le Directeur Général
euh madame la Présidente messieurs les
les les sénateurs ce que je vous propose
c'est sur les la partie spécifique
déclaration de soupçon Patrick suet vous
répondre Jean-François Mazo pourra
rentrer peut-être plus encore dans le
détail que moi sur les fondations je
vais vous apporter quelques éléments de
réponse mais je voudrais je voudrais
revenir sur sur votre interpellation
finalement que je comprends tout à
fait au fond comment comprendre comment
s'assurer que c'est sociétés offshore
sont conformes finalement
comment un client particulier classique
peut lui comprendre ce monde je je le
comprends très bien je vis juste au fond
vous expliquer
pourquoi nous sommes dans les métiers de
banque privée
international voilà pourquoi nous sommes
dans les métiers de banque privée
internationale
absolument alors la Société générale
c'est vrai depuis son origine elle a été
créée il y a plus de 150 ans
a dès le début une vocation déjà
internationale 2 ans après sa création
on partait à Londres on avait un réseau
en Russie qui est un des plus important
ant avant la Révolution russe bref le
cœur de l'ADN Société Générale ça a
toujours été d'aller déjà à
l'international cette activité
historique aussi s'est appuyée d'abord
sur des relations avec des
entreprises puis on s'est développé avec
des clients particulier et les clients
de banqu privées je mentionnais un
métier relativement jeune
1996 dans sa
structuration alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'on on continue à avoir déjà ce type
d'ambition internationale là on va
pourrait passer il faudrait passer plus
de temps mais nous sommes dans un monde
où nous considérons vous le savez que
notre métier notre modèle de banque dite
universel alors c'est pas tout à fait
universel parce que comme vous voyez on
s'est on est sorti d'un certain nombre
d'activités de de pays mais que la
combinaison d'activités celle que vous
connaissez dans vos territoire les
réseaux sociétés générales avec des
agences le métier de banque de détail
classique mais aussi au service
d'entreprise euh et et n'oublions jamais
que au service euh des des entreprises
il y a la moitié de notre résultat de
banque de détail est faite au service
des PME euh mais aussi la combinaison
avec des activités plus internationale
d'accompagnement des grandes entreprises
mais aussi et je vais revenir sur la
banque privée en particulier pour vous
expliquer un peu ce que nous faisons
stratégiquement sur la Banque Privée
font partie d'un modèle diversifié qui
au fond dans les toutes les contraintes
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui dans le
monde bancaire vous savez je sais qu'on
est face à des défis multiples de
réglementation euh d'environnement de
taux d'intérêt de digitalisation ce
modèle diversifié nous permet de
continuer à avoir un projet motivant
pour nos salariés motivant pour nos
actionnaires de développement et au fond
de faire face le cas échéant à une crise
qui peut se développer par rapport à une
banque qui serait dans un seul pays ou
dans une seule activité donc il nous
semble dans le monde incertain dans
lequel on est on a envie de continuer à
avoir un modèle diversifié qui pose très
bien et vous posez très bien la question
au fond je je et je je l' et moi-même on
fut comment facilement expliquer par
exemple y compris à nos salariés réseau
France ce qu'on fait en banque privée je
je je suis confronté à cette question
donc je je mesure
parfaitement l'idée en tout cas je peux
vous dire que d'un point de vue
stratégique l'objectif qu'on poursuit
c'est justement si les activités sont
diversifiées en revanche de partager une
culture commune un code de conduite
commun qui va bien au-delà des sujets de
fiscalité de de faire en sorte que les
145000 personnes de ce groupe
travaillent ensemble au service de
clients commun alors comment est-ce
qu'on travaille ensemble au service de
clients communs y compris dans cette
banque privée sur la banque privée par
exemple en France on a mis en place là
aussi Jean-François Mazo pour répondre
plus en détail à des questions si vous
en avez un un nouveau modèle où on
permet à nos
clients individuels comme les chefs
d'entreprise de PME qui ont bien souvent
des des aspects aussi patrimoniaux en
tête on a mis en place un modèle intégré
où on leur assure à eux leurs services
bancaires leur compte courant leur carte
de crédit pour leur famille et cetera
mais aussi un un service à leurs
entreprises qui peut aller depuis euh
l'aide au financement d'une acquisition
s'ils ont en tête l'accompagnement dans
la session de l'entreprise s'ils veulent
au contraire céder leur entreprise tous
les services financiers de cash
management l'accès à l'exportation à
travers nos réseaux donc ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que par rapport
peut-être à l'idée que vous avez mais
qui au fond c'est juste une somme
d'activités qui sont pas
cohérentes je peux vous garantir que
l'objectif au contraire que l'on a c'est
de les gérer de manière totalement
cohérente et pour vous donner juste un
chiffre parce que je vux pas vous
abreuver de chiffres mais on a dans le
cadre de nos résultats euh trimestriels
communiqués le le montant de
revenus généré par plusieurs métiers
plusieurs géographie au sein de Société
Générale et ben c'est 30 % du total pour
vous montrer que nous nous ne sommes pas
un ensemble disparate d'activités non
cohérente mais qu'au contraire on essaie
au maximum de d'avoir un ensemble
d'activités cohérent et je répète en
synergie alors effectivement vous le
dites très bien pour un particulier
français qui a son compte en banque à la
Société Générale ou ailleurs c'est c'est
l'idée d'avoir à structurer son
patrimoine parce que vous avez des
propriétés comme le disait le cas
échéant Patrick au Brésil à Londres aux
États-Unis des actions de multiples
entreprises mais c'est vrai que c'est la
réalité d'un d'un certain nombre de
clients patrimoniaux et moi je ne juge
pas je parte pas jugement moral pour
savoir si c'est bien ou pas d'avoir ce
type de patrimoine mais mais c'est une
réalité et nous ne sommes pas les seuls
je répète nous sommes la 15e banque
privée européenne en taille d'actif nous
sommes donc plutôt un acteur assez
modeste sur ces activités de banque
privée comme je le disais c'est 3 % de
nos revenus totaux bon voilà pour là
aussi remettre en perspective ces
activités mais la question que vous
posez est est parfaitement légitime je
la comprends parce que dans ce monde il
faut qu'on soit capable d'expliquer et
c'est pour ça que moi je me réjouis
d'avoir cette cette session de passer le
temps avec vous d'expliquer y compris à
nos salariés y compris à nos clients y
compris à nos actionnaires c'est c'est
totalement notre notre devoir
et c'est mon rôle en tant que que
directeur général
alors quand vous
dites je crois PASF à travers les
chiffres que j'ai quand même illustré je
crois pas qu'on puisse dire on encourage
je l'ai dit aucune société crée nouvelle
on en a avec mossac fonseeka 66 vous
avez vu le nombre de résidents fiscaux
français c'est un tout petit
nombre dans cette compétition
internationale la question c'est face à
une demande de clients est-ce qu'au fond
on on on on assure ce service si les
autres le
font je n'ai pas à commenter je pense
que en ce qui concerne les autres
banques françaises et les autres banques
européennes à vrai dire moi je n'ai pas
l'information euh je vois sortir un
certain nombre d'informations dans les
journaux à nouveau sur d'autres mais je
pense que la CPR pourra vous donner plus
d'informations sur ce point mon
sentiment en tout cas c'est que nous ne
sommes pas la seule banque au regarde de
toutes les informations sorties à voir
je crois qu'il y a 350 banques ensuite
le choix des prestataire a plus varier
bref je je ne sais pas si ce qui a été
communiqué donne la photo complète du de
de des activités de l'ensemble des
banques européennes mais nous sommes
dans une concurrence internationale ce
que nous essayons de faire comme que
j'ai essayé de vous expliquer c'est si
nous sommes amenés à créer à la demande
d'un client une société de ce type et
assurer un service fiduciaire en tout
cas avec les procédures que nous avons
le mettre en totale conformité fiscale
c'est ce que ce qu'on a essayé de vous
expliquer quant au manque à
gagner pareil je ne me sens pas
compétent pour vous répondre enfin je
pense que quelqu'un que ce soit la
direction des services fiscaux ù la CPR
aurait une vision beaucoup plus large
que que moi mais en ce qui nous concerne
je je je l'ai dit nous nous avons neuf
résidents fiscaux français concernant
six sociétés au Panama euh vous voyez
que c'est un enjeu extraordinairement
modeste et en plus pour nous en
conformité fiscale j'insiste nous avons
fait les vérification et nous
considérons qu'ils sont en conformité
fiscale donc en le spè je pense qu'il
n'y a pas personnellement de manque à
gagner alors sur les fondations et et je
répète je il n'y a aucun lien
capitalistique entre Société Générale et
nous sur ces fondations deuxièmement euh
nous avons eu au au maximum ces
fondation été crées en 2009 30 clients
aujourd'hui il y en a
deux aucun résident fiscal français
euh voilà donc pour là aussi mettre en
perspective ce sujet alors peut-être sur
les déclarations de soupçon Patrick suet
et Jean-François Mazo d'accord sur les
déclarations de soupson juste pour bien
préciser le chiffre qui a était
communiqué à madame la Présidente à ça
demande le chiffre de 70 déclarations de
soupçon ce sont les déclarations de
soupçon lié à l'existence d'une société
offshore ça représente environ un tiers
des déclarations dans le monde de la
banque privée donc il y a donc de tiers
qui n'étaient pas liés à autre à cela
les autres raisons sont assz enfin vous
pouvez les imaginer assez classiquement
euh il peut y avoir un doute sur un
éventuel abus de bien social des des
sources de revenus dont on considère
qu'elles sont pas suffisamment
claires et donc pourrait être
frauduleuse enfin on voit les ce sont
les bases classiques de de la lutte
antiblanchiment juste pour montrer que
ceci quand même ne concerne que la
banque privée internationale en France
s'agissant de la France et cette fois-ci
je je prends l'ensemble du réseau
Société Générale en France nous déposons
2700 déclaration de soupçon par an c'est
le chiffre de l'année dernière c'est un
chiffre en augmentation constante
d'ailleurs euh et c'est et ceci est le
même train que celui observé par Tracfin
dans ses rapports dans ses rapports
récent on les a multiplié par 10 depuis
2009 et là on voit l'impact de
l'introduction de la fraude fiscale dans
le champ du blanchiment et quoi 40 % à
peu près des déclarations0 c'est 40 %
sont liés à à à une un soupçon de fraude
fiscale alors voilà peut-être peut-être
je tu peux entrer un tout peu plus en
détail dans la prestation oui alors il
s'agit pour pour les fondations
d'assurer le le le vote ENF la
représentation dans le vote dans les les
assemblées en fait donc elles ont un
rôle fiduciaire à ce
titre et comme le disait Frédéric oua la
Société générale n'a pas de lien
capitalistique avec ses fondations hein
voilà voilà euh je peux peut-être juste
compléter un comme si vous le souhaitez
je peux peut-être compléter un point un
mot sur la la la Société Générale en
France et en ce qui concerne la Banque
Privée spécifiquement on a fait
exactement le mouvement
euh je dirais inverse d'un certain
nombre d'acteurs de banque privée euh
nous avons décidé en France de renforcer
notre banque privée sur le territoire
nous étions présents physique dans
villes en matière de banque privée nous
avons décidé de nous implanter dans 80
villes et justement pour être au plus
près des
entrepreneur au contact avec l'économie
réelle dans ce qui est quand même un
sujet très important qui est justement
la succession la transmission des
entreprises et nous avons un rôle ici à
jouer et nous considérons que ce
métier spécifiquement est
particulièrement Jea positionné pour
répondre à cette problématique et aussi
en lien évidemment avec la partie je la
banque de
financement au sein du réseau Société
Générale donc nous avons mené cet effort
ce qui nous a amené d'ailleurs quand on
regarde l'équilibre entre la partie je
dirais domestique du métier de banque
privée aujourd'hui et la partie non
domestique du métier a changé a inversé
en fait les POS relatifs sur la période
2012-25 merci beaucoup une autre série
de questions
vous poser Françis Maurice Vincent
Philippe dominatti et marieance
beauf François Marc merci madame la
Présidente les exigences citoyennes
aujourd'hui et la nécessité de se
prémunir contre les risques ont conduit
à des adaptations lourdes dans les
établissement bancaires c'est vrai
s'agissant des paradis fiscaux et c'est
vrai de toutes ces évolutions en cours
en ce moment pour
justement mettre au clair la situation
des établissements moi j'ai j'ai
consulté ce matin les statistiques qui
sont parues dans la presse sur justement
cette adaptation s'agissant du problème
qui nous réunit ce matin et s'agissant
notamment des des grands groupes
bancaires chez mossac Fonseca j'ai noté
les chiffres j'ai constaté que deux
choses j'ai constaté que pour la Société
générale il y Ava eu un un un
désengagements très rapides depuis 2011
euh c'est c'est le mouvement même le
plus rapide des établissements et puis
j'ai constaté une deuxième chose c'est
que toutes les banques françaises
étaient dans le jeu c'est-à-dire que
c'est un phénomène qui dépasse
visiblement euh le le cas d'un d'un seul
établissement donc ça c'est une réalité
je pense qu'il faut qu'on ait à l'esprit
mais si tous les établissements sont en
ce moment en train de mettre de l'ordre
d'une façon rapide dans ces situations
je pense que l'exigence citoyenne euh
trouve son compte j'ai une question à
poser concernant une deuxième exigence
qui va s'imposer aux éisements bancaires
et ceci relativement à l'évolution de la
réglementation à venir euh pour se
préinir contre les effets et les risques
du Shadow bankier euh il y a une
réglementation qui va se mettre en place
et qui vise à euh renforcer les limites
sur l'exposition individuelle des
banques aux entités du système financier
parallèle donc euh veillez à ce que euh
il y ait la plus grande transparence et
la moindre exposition possible des
banques à euh des systèmes parallèles
dont on ne maîtrise pas très bien euh
les tenants et les aboutissants et où la
transparence n'est pas la qualité
première donc est-ce que cette
réglementation qui va se mettre en place
sous l'égide du Conseil de stabilité
financière euh va entraîner aussi des
euh évolutions et des adaptations
importantes pour les établissements
bancaire je profite aujourd'hui de la
Réunion pour essayer d'anticiper sur
cette évolution à venir dès lors qu'une
réglementation plus contraignante va se
mettre en place sur ce thème qui est
aussi un thème je pense où l'exigence
citoyenne est clairement
manifestée Maurice Vincent ensuite
Philippe dominetti
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Directeur Général pour vos
vos explications moi je voulais vous
vous interroger puisque vous nous avez
enfin vous avez voulu nous Assur en tout
cas sur la rigueur des procédures en
place dans dans votre société pour
justement éviter tout risque de à ce que
j'ai compris en tout cas tout risque de
glissement de d'un conseil qui peut être
un conseil à l'optimisation fiscale mais
légale éviter le glissement évidemment
dans le cas de fraude parce que je pense
que c'est l'une des questions sans doute
à la fois les plus importantes et
peut-être aussi les plus difficiles
d'ailleurs à à résoudre mais je voulais
vous interroger
sur l'attitude et éventuellement les les
procédures qui sont mises en œuvre à la
Société Générale au regard d'éventuelles
lanceurs d'alerte c'estàdire par rapport
à vos personnels c'est une très grande
éid une très grande banque multiples
bureaux implantation il peut y
avoir une dérive voir une dérive grave
que se passe-t-il si vous êtes j'imagine
qu'à ce moment-là vos salariés sont
incités à tirer le signal d'alarme que
se passe-t-il comment vous gérez cela il
y a eu des choses extrêmement choquantes
dans d'autres banques qui ont été en
tout cas diffus
qui choque à mon avis à juste titre le
grand public quelle est votre attitude
est-ce qu'il y a justement de chez vous
des procédure particulière de protection
en particulier de
protection merci philippe Dominati
ensuite marie-fance
Beaufils Monsieur le Directeur Général
moi je voudrais revenir sur le profil
des comptes évoqués on est bien d'accord
il n'y a pas de société commerciale on
parle que de particulier ou de fondation
familiale mais je veux dire il n'y a pas
euh de sociétés euh au sens commercial
du terme qui sont dans les comptes
concernés deuxièmement vous parlez d'un
chiffre de 3 % pour l'activité
de patrimonial des banques privé ces 3 %
concernent l'ensemble je des activités
similaires ou simplement le Panama et
enfin euh en terme d'activité est-ce
qu'elle dégage des revenus c'est du
chiffre d'affaires ou des revenus c'est
les trois précisions que je voulais
avoir merci marie-fance befice
oui monsieur le
Président vous avez dit tout à
l'heure tous les trois que les clients
pouvaient être intéressés à certains
moment pour créer une société
offshore et que vous vérifiez si cette
volonté n'était pas lié pour du
blanchiment et donc dans ces cas-là ce
qui vous ferait retirer
votre intérêt pour le client concerné et
je n'arrive pas bien à comprendre quel
autre intérêt autre que fiscal peut être
celui de constituer une société offshore
donc si vous pouviez m'éclairer sur ce
sujet je je je n'arrive pas bien à à
m'imaginer quel autre intérêt pourrait
exister donc si vous pouviez nous
éclairer sur ce
sujet je serais intéressé à cela vous
avez dit également que vous aviez donc
retiré vos
implantations dans des pays qui
pouvaient être concernés par ces
questions d'version fiscale mais si vous
avez des clients qui vous sollicitent
est-ce que vous avez toujours une
activité dans ces pays dans ce domaine
et à ce moment-là quels sont ces types
d'activités et dernière question
euh vous nous avez dit que
cette la part euh d'activités que que
vous
aviez dans sur sur ces domaines liés à
des clients
demandant une pratique offshore ça
représenté à peu près 3 % de vos revenus
totaux si j'ai bien compris euh moi
j'aimerais savoir si euh vous pourriez
nous donner
parallèlement comment évolue euh votre
intervention en tant que banque plus
largement dans le domaine du financement
de l'économie et dans le domaine du
financement des infrastructures et
particulièrement en France c'està-dire
quelle est la proportion que vous
consacrez et est-elle en évolution
positive ou non Monsieur le Directeur
Général peut-être si vous me permettez
clarifier les chiffres parce que vous
allez voir que l'activité dont on parle
est infinitésimale même par rapport à 3
% la Société générale c'est grosso modo
25 milliards d'euros de revenus dans
l'ensemble de ces
activités ensemble des activités de
banque privée
l'ensemble représente à peu près 3 % du
total
l'activité de service fiduciaire aux
sociétés offshore dont on parle là aussi
je parle de mémoire mais c'est de
l'ordre de c'est quoi 2 millions 2
millions d'euros
donc l'activité dont on parle c'est 2
million d'euros rapporté à 25 milliards
si je ne me trompe pas c'est donc du
0,01 % du total enfin je me trompe pas
dans mes calcul
calcul même à zé bon enfin
bref ce que je veux dire non mais ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que c'est une
activité totalement marginal tant dans
les nombres que je vous ai communiqué
que dans les revenus générés et ça ne se
pardon mais mais je prends votre point
madame la sénatrice attendez je prends
totalement votre ça rejoint le mais vous
voyez à quel point non mais vous voyez à
quel point c'est dans un souci selon
nous d'apporter un service au clients et
qu'on essaie de faire en totale
conformité comme je l'ai expliqué ça
n'est pas une source de revenu
significative du total mais vous posez
une excellente question je je auquel
nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui je le
mesure ayant le la charge de la
réputation du groupe le le le le poids
que ça peut avoir en en image et la
complexité d'expliquer donc je je je je
prends totalement son point mais je je
voulais juste rétablir les chiffres pour
montrer à quel point c'est totalement
petit alors
ensuite je voudrais revenir sur le le
shadow banking la la la question de du
sénateur
Marc d'abord qu'est-ce qu'on appelle
shadow banking là aussi il faut qu'on
soit clair c'est au fond en général
c'est un terme qui qui est un peu
péjoratif mais c'est tout ce qui n'est
pas régulé d'un point de vue bancaire ce
sont des acteurs de nature très
différent ça des compagnies d'assurance
des gestionnaires d'actifs ce qu'on
appelle les Hed fund vous savez donc des
gestionnaires d'actifs mais enfin qui
ont des stratégies plutôt d'arbitrage de
court terme c'est le le monde du private
equity des acteurs vous savez qui lèvent
beaucoup de fonds et puis qui achète des
entreprises qui ne sont pas forcément
listées bon ce qui est clair c'est que
avec les contraintes qui se sont
effectuées sur les banques ce monde
s'est
développé la masse s'est développé et
j'auderis vous dire que c'est voulu par
les superviseurs et les régulateurs les
les les personnes qui
final les personnes si vous voulez qui
qui ont imaginé le monde bancaire
nouveau si on dit il faut que les
banques soient un peu plus petites
extrêmement bien protégé ce qui est
légitime pour ne pas peser sur les
contribuables mais au fond on accepte
comme conséquence qu' est plus de risque
dans le secteur nonbancaire dans la
mesure où les contribuables n'ont pas à
venir à l'aide en principe de ces
acteurs non bancaires donc c'est une
vision acceptée assumée en quelque sorte
alors ce qui est totalement exact comme
vous le dites c'est que on a une somme
de contraintes de toute nature là je
veux pas entrer trop dans la technique
faut là aussi il faudrait passer plus de
temps mais qui sont la gestion de notre
capital la gestion de la liquidité les
règles applicables justement lorsqu'on a
une relation par exemple y compris avec
une autre banque qui vont nous
contraindre et nous limiter parce que la
vision des superviseurs c'est plutôt de
se dire je veux réduire les liens qui
associent les banques ou l'ensemble des
acteurs financiers entre eux et donc ils
sont en train de mettre des contraintes
qui font que régulièrement encore
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas commencé ça ne
commence pas aujourd'hui ça a commencé
maintenant depuis 5 ans les modèles
bancaires changent profondément pour
autant ces acteurs non bancaire eux ils
peuvent faire appel à l'épagne le
caséchant lever de l'argent auprès
d'investisseur en en direct sans avoir
besoin de nos propres financement voilà
je pense ce sera un débat qui mériterait
bien sûr de passer plus de temps mais
mais c'est vrai que il y a une évolution
dans ce domaine les lanceurs d'alertes
monsieur le sénateur Vincent euh il y a
un dispositif qui existe à la Société
Générale et on va dire d'une manière
plus générale dans les banques euh quand
on raisonne système de contrôle et de
conformité le lanceur d'alerte et le
dispositif le protégeant et le système
qui va permettre sur la base d'une
alerte d'aller vérifier ce qui peut-être
dit hein parce que il peut y avoir des
alertes qui soient pas fondées il faut
être bien sûr il faut aller vérifier
existe et et fait partie de la panoplie
on va dire alors c'est justement ce
lanceurs d'alerte alerte la conformité
he de manière anonyme et nous avons
c'est là où nous avons une inspection
générale et un corp d'audit là aussi qui
en dehors des 1800 de personnes de la
conformité on a à peu près
1350 inspecteurs et auditeurs dans le
monde à ce moment-là si on a on sent
qu'il y a une matière on envoie
l'inspection pour aller regarder le
sujet creuser la la véracité des choses
Patrick su pourra peut-être entrer un
peu plus dans le
détail madame la sénatrice alors le
question donc j'ai répondu je pense à la
taille relative de ces activité qui sont
microscopique
oui nous finançons l'économie alors
d'abord d'une manière générale le
secteur bancaire français vous le savez
finance l'économie les prêts que ce soit
au particulier ou aux entreprises
augment aujourd'hui à plus de 4 % en
rythme annuel comparé à une moyenne euh
pour les entreprises en tout cas j'ai le
chiffre de 0,6 sur la zone euro je si
vous me permettez de reprendre un
instant ma casquette de président de la
Fédération bancaire française je je peux
affirmer que le système bancaire
français finance mieux l'économie que
partout ailleurs en zone euro nous-même
nous continuons à faire croîre nos
encours euh nos encours aux entreprises
et nos encours euh aux particuliers
nous sommes entrés ça c'est un chiffre
qu'on a communiqué dans notre
communication financière par exemple
nous sommes entrés en relation avec 1000
entreprises français supplémentair rien
que sur le premier trimestre c'est un
chiffre qui est publique he qui figure
dans nos slides donc pour nous le
développement de notre activité en
France est essentielle nous avons la
chance de conquérir des clients que ce
soit des clients particuliers ou des
clients
entreprise alors peut-être tu veux
compléter
monsieur sur le
juste pour l'ampleur ENF et l'historique
du dispositif c'est pas du tout un
dispositif nouveau pour nous on a mis en
place en 2006 un un code de conduite sur
l'ensemble du groupe donc c'est pas
seulement en France qui comporte une
partie consacrée au lanceur d'alerte
avec une procédure un numéro de
téléphone je se trouve que quand j'étais
secrétaire général c'était mon numéro de
téléphone ça c'était un un système dédié
aux alertes et et et donc la personne
bien entendu appelle directement ou
laisse un message directement et ensuite
on met en place le dispositif d'enquête
Sonel la modalité la plus adaptée pour
nous assurer que le que ce dispositif
fonctionne donc c'est bien un dispositif
group c'est un dispositif ancien et nous
sommes en voie de le de le rénover
puisque le monde des lanceurs d'alertes
sur le plan juridique évoluent beaucoup
il y a des lanceurs d'alerte maintenant
notamment qui peuvent alerter
directement les régulateurs le
dispositif est en cours de fabrication
donc nous allons voir comment nous
adaptons nos dispositifs pour les rendre
encore plus efficaces et améliorer aussi
la protection des lanceurs d'alerte
puisque c'est le pendant du bon
fonctionnement du dispositif des
lanceurs
d'alerte merci beaucoup un complément il
y avait un complément peut-être juste
pour expliquer à madame la sénatrice le
les différentes typologies hein de vous
avez posé cette cette question tout à
l'heure donc transmettre un patrimoine
c'est préparer la transmission d'un
patrimoine la plupart du temps donc il
s'agit de regrouper en fait des des
actifs au sein d'une société pour
pouvoir ensuite transmettre les parts de
cette société à des enfants à des
héritiers voilà ça c'est un exemple très
je pense pour répartir des actifs si par
exemple vous avez des biens immobiliers
un peu partout dans le monde vous dites
ce bien va aller à tel personne tel
autre avec une société qui est
identifiée et attachée au bien plutôt
que d'avoir une société globale euh qui
couvrirait l'ensemble des biens le
deuxième sujet donc recouvre ce que
disait Frédéric oua c'est organiser les
avoirs organiser le patrimoine euh les
clients peuvent avoir intérêt à scinder
à organiser leur patrimoine en
compartiment euh et à faciliter
d'ailleurs d'une certaine façon la
session euh parfois en cours de vie
parfois dans le cadre d'une succession
de ce patrimoine donc c'est une deuxième
dimension qui est qui est qui est voilà
qu'on peut illustrer de cette façon une
troisième explication donc
l'organisation de la vie des affaires ça
peut être préparer l'achat ou la vente
d'un actif donc au travers d'une d'une
société qui va venir porter une
acquisition d'un actif patrimonial donc
on peut voilà on peut avoir ce genre de
situation toujours on revient sur ce que
l'on a expliqué tout à l'heure nous
allons nous poser la question de
savoir à nouveau dans quel but ces
opérations sont faites et et si elles
sont conformité avec les lois les
réglementations qui doivent être
appliqué vous confir ce que je ressens
c'est-à-dire que c'est bien pour des
raisons fiscales pour l'essentiel que
que le chemin se fait non pour des
raisons patrimoniales madame la
sénatrice voyez c'est c'est ensuite
c'est quand même la réflexion fiscale
qui est derrière la notion de patrimoine
pas pas pas nécessairement la la raison
fiscale vous savez il il y a des gens on
a des clients sans citer des nom par
exemple qui sont dans des endroits où il
y a pas de fiscalité on peut avoir des
clients à Dubaï où il ne payent pas
d'impôt mais la répartition la
structuration la répartition à travers
des des entités juridiques qui leur
permettent une nouvelle fois de céder
s'ils le souhaitent tel ou telle société
tel ou tel actif facilement par rapport
à une autre qui serait globale avec la
complexité des droits si si vous
imaginez quelqu'un qui a un patrimoine
réparti dans le monde aux États-Unis au
Royaume Uni et cetera ça peut être plus
simple d'avoir un cloisonnement de ce
patrimoine parce que les régimes de
toute nature pas seulement fiscaux mais
juridique attaché aux sessions peuvent
être différents et d'une certaine
manière ça peut être plus simple de
cloisonner dans des patrimoines très
diversifiés par rapport à la situation
standard peut-être d'un d'un citoyen
français qui a son patrimoine en France
exclusivement euh une dernière série de
questions puisque nous nous acheminons
vers la conclusion André gâolin et
Michel canevette ont solliciter la
parole André gatolin merci madame la
Présidente je voulais revenir sur
l'impact je dirais des révélations de
Panama papers et notamment concernant la
société mossac
fonsseeka on a beaucoup expliqué en tous
les cas dans les médias que l'absence de
sociétés américaines ou de grands nom
américains était lié au fait que il
courait déjà depuis plusieurs mois VO
plusieurs années des alertes d'un
certain nombre d'instances américaines
concernant cette société est-ce que vous
vous avez eu vent puisque vous dites
vous-même vous avit procédé au retrait
je dirais de ces comptes
panaméens donc ça c'est un un des aspect
parce que je veux pas croire que vous
soyez les perdreux de l'année donc vous
avez aussi des informations et quand la
matière chacun surveille ce qui se
produit partout il n'empêche que ça me
pose indirectement une question parce
que quand on voit que beaucoup de ces
comptes ont été ouverts à partir pas
seulement votre établissement parce que
j'ai cru comprendre il y a une alerte
qui qui vient de tomber le journal de
mond le monde à partir des Panama paper
et tout à l'heure donc va s'occuper du
business sofshore de deux de vos grands
concurrents la BNP et le Crédit Agricole
qui voilà donc il y a semble-t-il de
nouveaux éléments qui devraient paraître
mais je je vais pas vous demander de les
commenter puisque nous les découvrons à
l'instant mais j'ai l'impression que
est-ce que une grande banque quel que
soit je dirais la visibilité qu'on ait
et le suivi est-ce qu'elle est toujours
en mesure de contrôler totalement les
choix et
l'activité de ces filiales on a eu des
cas de trader dans un autre domaine qui
prenaient des
options au-delà de ce qui semble-t-il
l'UR été autorisé ça c'est ma principale
question puis la seconde question vous
bien sûr cette affaire provoque beaucoup
d'émois dans les médias dans l'opinion
publique mais est-ce que vous en tant
que Société Générale au niveau France
parmi vos clients et notamment les
particuliers vous avez des questions des
demandes et puis je dit toujours quand
on entre dans une banque en signe un
contrat alors on a beaucoup beaucoup de
lignes nous expliquant les procédures
est-ce qu'il y a pas une question
peut-être aussi pour rétablir peut-être
une confiance si demain elle est
affectée d'une véritable charte
peut-être plus lisible que ce qui est
fait parce que bien sûr on est sous
l'autorité de telle réglementation mais
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas dire
aujourd'hui au simples clients
particulier ou autres petit des petites
entreprises quells sont en gros la
charte de ce qu'on fait en matière de de
régulation au niveau international
est-ce que vous envisagez ce type de
solution je vous remercie merci Michel
canvette merci merci madame la
Présidente notre collègue Richard Jong
tout à l'heure évoqué le fait que ce
soit de la Société Générale qu'on ait le
plus parlé dans l'affaire des Panama
papers sans doute est-ce parce que c'est
là qu'il y avait le plus grand nombre de
sociétés offshore 485 en 2011 11 jusqu'à
66 avez avez-vous dit tout à l'heure euh
ici euh est-ce que la diminution du
nombre de sociétés offshore donc
est-elle le fait comme dans les
établissements bancaires qui vient
d'être qui viennent d'être cité de
l'externalisation des des comptes ou
alors est-ce que c'est la fermeture pure
et simple première question deuxème
question sur les 66 comptes qu'il reste
est-ce que la stratégie de la Société
Générale va être de les fermer
complètement ou allez-vous en conserver
quelques-uns et et dans
l'affirmative pour quelle raison
allez-vous les conserver et enfin on a
parlé de mossac foneka mais y y a-t-il
d'autres comptes offshore chez d'autres
opérateurs et quel est le nombre s'il y
en a actuellement à la Société Générale
merci Monsieur le Directeur Général
merci Monsieur le Directeur général je
vais ajouter une question mais elle
complète un peu celle de notre collègue
Michel canvette
euh voilà le quel rôle le rôle qui est
joué par la société euh général dans la
société offshore elle est mise en place
admettons elle est là est-ce que vous
avez un levier d'action ou des levier
d'action vous Société Générale pour
mettre fin à l'activité est-ce que ça
vous échappe ou est-ce que il y a encore
quelque chose qui est à votre
connaissance voilà et si vous pouvez
répondre à cette série de dernières
questions voilà nous essaierons d'aller
vers notre conclusion vers
13h alors je vais peut-être prendre déjà
la la la question relative à la relation
avec mossac fonsseeka euh et d'une
certaine manière comme vous le dites
mais je je je n'ai pas connaissance de
ces informations nous ne sommes pas la
seule banque internationale il y en a eu
350 peut-être qu'il y a d'autres banques
européennes et et françaises euh ce qui
montre que il n'y avait pas en tout cas
à ma connaissance de dispositif de de
d'information d'alerte particulier
adressé à la communauté bancaire
internationale
euh je vais bien sûr examiner toutes les
ces informations moi j'ai un principe si
vous voulez quand des informations de
presse circulent sur bah j'essaie de les
vérifier voilà bon en pratique comme je
l'ai dit nous n'avons pas ouvert de
société nouvelles au Panama avec cette
société depuis 2012 des facto donc on
est plus sur un stock de société
existante que de nouvelles bien entendu
d'une manière générale si ces
information étent confirmé on en tirera
les les conclusions et on va
s'interroger on va regarder s'il faut
forcer encore ce qu'on appelle les les
les contrôles et duion sur les
prestataires de service alors il n'y a
pas eu de ce point de vue pour revenir
aussi sur les questions posées alors
j'ai indiqué le nombre de sociétés avec
d'autres prestataires au Panama c'est
neuf il n'y a pas eu d'externalisation
la baisse pourquoi C baisse d'abord et
et je pense que cette baisse on la
retrouve aussi d'ailleurs dans d'autres
établissements c'est d'abord tout le
tout l'environnement qui a changé que
j'ai
décrit le renforcement des processus de
facto le fait que n'ayant pas ouvert de
nouvelles sociétés bah ell meurent ces
sociétés comme on le disait elle restent
pas 40 ans existant tout elle donc il y
a une diminution naturelle le fait je
rappelle que nous avons nous-même
refocalisé not notre fond de commerce
nous avons réduit notre fond de commerce
en cédant par exemple les clients
asiatiques le fait aussi que ces
activités de servicees fiduciaire à des
fins justement de concentration des
expertises et contrôles on les a
concentré dans deux endroits qui sont le
luxe embourg et la Grande-Bretagne du
coup imaginez un cliant par exemple en
Suisse à la limite il a pas forcément
envie de faire le trajet et il a pu
partir dans une autre banque si c'était
plus commode pour lui donc il y a une
somme d'explication on n'a pas été
capable je ne suis pas capable
aujourd'hui de regarder l'histoire de
toutes ces structures mais le nombre de
manière très
régulière c'est a diminué à partir du
moment où il y en avait pas de de
nouvelles sur la l'impact clientèle à
date il n'y a pas d'impact significatif
vis-à-vis de notre
clientèle et et et et je crois que c'est
très important justement que je fasse
cet exercice d'explication de
transparence qui est diffusé en interne
tout ce que je vous dis là va être
répercuté vous en aviez la primeure mais
est répercuté en interne à nos salariés
à charge pour eux aussi bien sûr
d'expliquer cela s'il y a des questions
à des clients mais d'une manière
générale
il n'y a pas d'impact aujourd'hui
spécifique sur ces 66 comptes et ça
alors madame la Présidente je passerai
la parole à Jean-François Mazo pour vous
expliquer la type d'action qu'on peut
avoir on a une action concrète on peut
fermer des comptes il va vous expliquer
ça en cohérence avec ce que je dit pour
nous les
66 sont conforme fiscalement alors je
vais à nouveau vérifier que nos
procédures sont suffisamment buste sur
les 66 qui restent pour s'assurer qu'il
y a pas un sujet qui pose problème bien
entendu mais a priori pour l'instant je
n'ai pas décidé d'interrompre ce service
qui est comme vous l'avez vu marginal
dès lors que on pense que ce sont des
clients qui sont conforme et et je
voudrais réinsister pour moi l'échange
automatique d'information est absolument
décisif un client français un résident
fiscal français aujourd'hui qui serait
avec la Société Générale et aurait une
activité de ce type Shore c'est c'est
c'est fait la photo est prise que la
photo est transmise euh au sil est au
Luxembourg l'année prochaine et suite
sur la photo de donc il le sait donc je
pense C en complément des des procédures
que l'on met en place que j'espère on
met en place de manière la plus
disciplinée possible si vous voulez
c'est un filet de sécurité tout de même
important cet échange automatique
d'information voilà on va continuer à
réexaminer ça je ne m'interdis rien j'ai
pris note je vous avez parfaitement
raison de souligner l'impact en image
pour une activité marginale donc on on
va y réfléchir mais à ce stade je n'ai
pas pris de de décision alors peut-être
qu'est-ce quelle prise on a en quelque
sorte sur ces sociétés offshore oui
madame la Présidente donc pour répondre
à votre question on peut fermer les
comptes dans toute une série de
juridictions oou les gelés quand on ne
peut pas les fermé on les gèle donc ils
sont bloqués compartimentés et ils sont
identifiés comme le disait Frédéric ouéa
comme il y a l'échange automatique
d'information qui arrive de toute façon
l'information sera renvoyée aux
administrations fiscales des
implantations dans lesqueles nous sommes
présents dans les pays dans lesquels la
Banque Privée exerce donc typiquement la
Suisse ou le Luxembourg dans les deux
exemples qui ont été mentionné et
ensuite charge à l'administration
fiscale de ces pays de renvoyer
l'information à l'administration fiscale
des pays dans lesquels les clients sont
sont résidents donc on peut mener cette
action et en fait on l'amène euh dans le
cadre de la revue systématique de notre
fond de commerce que je mentionnais tout
à l'heure et qui a pour objet à la fin
de l'année 2016 d'avoir passé en vue
tous nos clients voilà donc c'est c'est
c'est une action très concrète avant de
fermer il y a aussi le travail qui peut
consister
à conseiller à des clients dont on
aurait compris qu'il pourrait ne pas
être conforme fiscalement à se
régulariser il y a aussi cette action là
cette action de régularisation qui
peut-être
mené alors les pays ont choisi des voies
diverses he sur ce sur cette question là
il y a des rythmes qui sont différents
des intensités qui sont différentes mais
nous menons systématiquement aussi cet
effort ce travail qui est de pousser à
la régularisation mais ultimement la
clôture ou le gel quand nous avons des
indice suffisamment concordant pour
penser que les clients ne sont pas
conformes fiscalement et et bien sûr on
parle
de compte nous n'avons pas de d'action
sur la société puisqu'elle est possédée
elle-même par les
clients merci beaucoup monieur le
directeur général Messieurs mes chers
collègues merci nous allons poursuivre
dans les semaines à venir des
auditions qui nous permettront sans
doute peut-être de revenir vers vous si
des précisions s'avit utile mais j'ai
compris que vous étiez disponible pour
le par et je vous en remercie et je
remercie nos collègues de s'intéresser à
ce sujet qui est un sujet extrêmement
important nous voyons bien combien même
la mise en œuvre de fatka par les
États-Unis a a obligé les pays à bouger
peut-être plus encore que d'autres
procédures mais soyons soyons conscients
de cela et et effectivement 2017 et 2018
les deux années qui seront de l'échange
automatique vont sans doute alléger vos
préoccupations et sans doute les nôtres
quel que soit notre avis ici dans cette
commission sur la manière dont dont nous
avons travaillé sur ces sujets et ce
matin voilà pour l'audition de Frédéric
ouea le directeur général de la Société
Générale qui s'est donc exprimé devant
les sénateurs sur la question de
l'évasion fiscale à la suite du scandale
des Panama papers Frédéric ouea qui
finalement n'a pas été poursuivi pour
faux témoignage par le bureau du Sénat
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes nos auditions sur notre site
publsenat.fr très bonne journée sur les
chaînes
parlementaires